Hey, what's going on is bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday
morning podcast. And I,
okay,
just checking in on you. How's it going?
How are you? How's your week going? Oh,
that's wonderful.
Now I know a lot of you guys last Monday
were very upset with me when I was
speaking in code and you just couldn't,
you know, about my European tour.
You were like, well, wait a minute.
It rhymes with bundling mingle and well,
where the hell would that be?
I'm not some sort of sleuth.
I can't figure that stuff out.
I got to start breaking down code.
This isn't what I signed up for.
I signed up to listen to a angry
half a Leprechaun, you know,
bitch above getting a
sunburn. Um, all right,
well I can actually announced some dates.
I don't know why I can't
announce all of them.
I don't know what the
big fucking secret is.
It's not like I'm going to go over
there to start spying on you. Uh,
but here's the ones we got so far actually
that the tickets are going to go on
sale. Um, I didn't know how
to fucking say these places.
Colston C o l s t o n hall in Bristol.
Um,
you k, um, announced five,
25 at 10:00 AM. All right,
so the tickets are on sale.
Oh, I, this is when I announce it.
Well, I'm announcing it on the 26. Um,
the tickets will go on sale on May 27th.
MMM.
At 10:00 AM B s t,
whatever the fuck that means.
Britain's standard time.
I don't know Billy stupid tits.
I have no idea. Um, you
can get those at live,
nation.com artists slash bill Byrd dash
two, whatever the link is on my, my, uh,
my website. That's going to
be August 3rd. On August 4th,
I'm gonna be in fucking Manchester,
Manchester,
England, home of Man United. Um,
I'm going to be there, um, on August 4th.
And uh, those tickets will also go on
those tickets go on sale on the 26th.
That's the Presale,
mmm.
To sell subscribers only.
Whatever the fuck that means.
I don't know what any of this shit means.
Um, for all you normal people, I guess,
who don't have cell phones
for all the old people. Um,
tickets for everybody else will go
on sale on May 27th at 10:00 AM uh,
Billy stupid tits time. Ah, um,
August 5th, where am I going to be
next? I'm going to be in London,
England at the Apollo.
Hammersmith.
Um, these things go on
sale. And uh, once again,
May 27th at 10:00 AM uh,
Britain standard time.
God Save the Queen Time. I
Dunno. Um, an August 8th,
I'm going to be adding in Edinburgh,
Scotland.
The folks still full. Could podcast,
uh, sorry for the bad accent. Uh,
pleasants grand two shows there.
I think I'm doing two in London too.
I can't remember. I don't know. Fuck.
I don't pretend to know these things.
Um,
those will also go on sale on
May 27th at 10:00 AM. All right.
And I got some dates.
I got three dates in Ireland too,
and I got a something in Amsterdam.
I think that'll be it.
Nice little 10 day fucking run there.
Go over there. You know, stare at you.
Pasty constancy. Where my freckles
came from. That's what I'm doing. Oh,
I can't wait.
I cannot fucking wait.
You know we are knee deep neck
deep into writing this season.
We've got the table read here and
a couple hours for episode five,
episode five, um, and we do six, seven,
eight in June and then
nine and 10 in July.
And then we fucking edit
them for the next 10 months,
not even 10 months,
whatever.
For the next six months we'll be adding
in all this fucking shit and we'll
basically have them and then they'll come
out may of next year and you guys will
sit down with a six pack of beer and
you'll burn through them in about three
hours and a like where the to
the next one. And you know what,
we'll make you some more cause
we're having a great time,
but I'm not going to lie to you.
Um,
it has become my life and I don't
know what the fuck's going on at all.
I know that Donald Trump
was here yesterday, um,
having a rally down in fucking Anaheim,
um,
which I thought was pretty perfect for
him to be head down towards Orange County
with whatever the fuck it is on his
head to talk to a bunch of people that,
you know, whatever the fuck they
did to their face. You know,
I swear to God, Hollywood gets such
good, so much shit for like, you know,
like everybody out here has plastic
surgery. I'm not saying they don't,
but at least it's decent.
Jesus Christ,
you go down a fucking orange county with
all those real housewives and those Wa
Bruce Jenner looking dudes.
You know what I mean?
Remember Bruce was still Bruce Bevan
when Caitlin was still Bruce and uh,
the dude had his eyes done, you know, and
the nose and all that. They all had like,
those fucking, I think at did
bit about that. My Act, I got,
we'll have the Bruce Jenner eyes and I
used to, I thought it was bullshit. I was,
you know,
my wife would watch the real housewives
of a housewives of Orange County.
I'd be like, all right. They picked
the six biggest psycho couples.
They could find people down here.
Don't look like this.
And then I went down to Irvine.
I was playing the Improv and I walked
around the mall and I was like,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
These fucking people at the,
I don't know what they're doing out here.
I think when you get into warmer client
climates and people have to wear less
clothes, they really start
doing the plastic surgery
shit. You know what I mean?
All you guys in those winter climates, you
can hide in your puffy coats, you know,
sport coat, buttoned down
shirt. I'll never forget that.
When I used to work in a warehouse when
I was a young lad, full head of hair,
fucking abs, the whole thing.
Half as many freckles, you know,
sunny outlook on life. Oh,
it was a long time ago.
I remember once a year we'd have the
company picnic and all these fucking suits
who look like they were in at least
halfway decent shape. They'd showed up.
They show up at t shirts and Holy Shit,
Jesus Christ,
the fucking rolls just
fucking spilling up,
pushing out the fuck tee shirts.
It was horrific.
I just remember looking
at these people going,
this guy's wearing the company this
time I'm taking orders from this tub of
shit. And they could feel it
too. It could feel it. Um,
it felt the eyes looking at him.
Shame. You can shame people. Good fat,
shame people back in 88, 89. Not
Anymore. Not Anymore. Now I'm,
now I'm the problem. Right. It's not their
fucking 8,000 calories a day. You know,
it's what happened to
them when they were six.
That's why they're written fucking ice
cream with candy bars in it. I'm sorry.
Anyways, let's plow ahead here. Yes.
So I have absolutely no idea what
the fuck is going on at anywhere,
at anytime.
Anything.
All I know is I'm in a fucking writers
from now evidently meet me in St Louis.
Louis meet me at the fair.
Evidently my Saint Louis Blues loss
last night, you know, they came back,
they tied it up for games.
There's two games to two.
And that's the last game I saw.
Cause I've been stuck in this fucking
room and I forgot to tape the last couple
of times. Um, you know, cause we, you
know, we had one every once in a while,
you just have a fucking a story
and you're trying to do it.
Everybody's got 15,000 notes. You know,
this isn't tracking. It's not on the page.
I don't think we earned this.
What's the motivation?
You've got to raise the stakes.
And for those of you not in the business,
that means you're not going to see
anybody you love for the next 48 hours.
So I missed everything. Evidently,
according to people on Twitter,
the sharks gave the blues,
the old right there, Fred,
and gained five and six sit
down and shut the fuck up.
My condolences to blues fans.
Um, I know you wanted more,
but a great season. You know,
you're beat the fucking blues.
You beat the fucking stars and then you
lost it. The fucking sharks. All right.
And I believe it was meatloaf
who said to add a three. Sorry.
Um, yeah, it's, that's
fucking brutal, man.
Especially when you get that deep into
the playoffs and then it's just fucking
over and then you just
sit in there and like,
now what do I do while you live in
Saint Louis? This is what you do.
You go to a cardinals game
and you'll watch the rams
pack up and leave your city,
and this is what you should do.
Rather than crying in your
fucking Peyton Manning,
partially owned beer.
Um,
what you should do is,
uh,
you guys ought to fucking talk to the
Arizona cardinals. Tell him to come back,
you know? I mean, that's what I would
do. Oh, what's your bill? No, I wouldn't,
I wouldn't even know how to begin.
I wouldn't know how to begin to go
about doing something like that.
Okay.
Yeah. I mean, I would have no idea how to,
I have no idea how to go about anything.
I'm one of those fucking guys,
you know what you should do.
You should fucking do this. So yeah, how
do you, how do you do that? And I'm like,
I'm like,
I'm like Donald Trump,
except I'm not running for president and
I'll build a fucking wall between here
and Mexico. I'm going to make
Mexico pay for it. Oh yeah.
How are you gonna do that,
Donald? Ah, the fucking guy.
Can you fucking believe that?
That, I mean, it's fun. It's, it's
Ben and Hillary Clinton.
I cannot believe people are going to
fucking vote for either one of them.
I just cannot fucking believe it.
Unfucking believable.
They'll vote for Hillary Clinton.
They'll put her in fucking office
and then bitch, that nothing changed.
How many fucking yeah, times. Remember
that Shit. We're going to fuck it.
We got a new guy. We got hope. It's
going to end the war. Close down.
Guantanamo Bay. It's a nothing
fucking chair. Nothing changed.
It's exact fucking shape. Dig.
And he got this fucking jerk off.
Who's just, Oh, he just says this. No
matter what. You bring up a Donald.
What's up with your shirt? This is the
best shirt. I have the best shirts.
I'll have the best shirts
of any president ever.
And this a fucking zillion people
losing their fucking minds going,
this guy, this guy's going
to turn it around. I guess.
He said the other day, you took a
physical, he's 69 years old. And he said,
the doctor said he had the, I have these
set, I had the, I have the best body,
the best body of any 69 year old he's
ever seen. Like how do you not see like,
you know what he's like, remember
that guy who wrote the twist Karma.
Let's do the twist, right? And
the next summary comes out, hey,
write another hit song.
Uh, twist again, luck.
We're dead last summer.
It's the same fucking song.
The guy actually breff
reference back. Like, you know,
do you remember when
I wrote the same song?
It was a year ago. Um, the
fuck was that guy's name.
I know it wasn't Charlie
Pride Chubby checker.
You know what's worse about anytime
you bring up Chubby Checker,
then somebody always has to tell you
the story of how he got his name. Well,
you know, there was fats, Domino's.
They said fats. Gebbie domino checker.
Yes.
Everybody's heard that story.
We all saw Dick Clark tell that story
and then everybody told it in the fucking
bars. You can't. Um, anyways, so. Oh,
I haven't given you guys
the update on my side.
I had a uh, oh, sorry.
Um,
I think I found the cure for it.
Okay.
I have not sat down for more than fucking,
I dunno,
six seconds for the last like 48 hours
and it seems to be doing wonders for me.
That's the hardest thing
about having Sattik.
Although one I drive to the
fucking office and come back. Um,
I basically stand up in the writer's
room and when I'm sick of standing,
I just laid down on the floor like one
of those fucking animals at the airport.
Some of the pictures you guys are
sending me to a fucking hilarious.
This guy sent me one with
this guy was like, you know,
they have the row of chairs.
He was sleeping underneath them,
like perpendicular to them.
So he had his legs,
his ass in his lower back were
underneath the chair laying on his front.
And then he was like holding onto like
his hooded sweatshirt that he was using
as a pillow. He had that all wrapped
with his head on the side. Like a,
like a little kid sleeping
with the stuffed animals.
MMM.
I mean like how long is your
flight been delayed that you,
you just lost that much?
I Dunno.
Respect for yourself that you're going to
fucking late. I mean, it was kitten who,
I mean, I get on a plane every once in
a while. It's a long fucking flight.
You know,
you might kick your shoes off,
you got your socks on and you keep
your socks on top of your shoe.
She might do something
like that for a minute.
Provided your feet don't fucking stink.
Provided you took a shower that day.
You got on some fucking fairly new
socks and a fairly new pair of sneakers.
It's not the wrong with that,
but Jesus Christ and he started walking
around the fucking plane going into the
bathroom animals. So anyways,
anyways, let me, let me, uh,
let me get back to the sports here.
So the blues are knocked out,
the sharks have made their first final,
um,
the calves kicked the fuck out of the,
the,
the raptors as far as I know. And
I've only, you know, like I said,
I just watch highlights of this shit.
Dumb ass fucking move was the raptors
to start doing the a wagging the finger.
Why would you do that? You know, hey,
we're finally starting to win here.
Why don't we a piss off the calves
and get them more motivated?
They only have Lebron
fucking James, you know, um,
and Okc is in the process of raping the,
uh,
yeah,
the fuck are they? The California seals
who they play in Golden State Warriors.
MMM.
Jesus Christ.
And I've missed all of it.
And I don't know anybody on any fucking
team. I mean other than the stars,
I know those guys. So I'm going
to shut up about it, but I am,
tonight I'm going to tape game
seven of the pens lightening.
And I'm also gonna take the,
uh,
the OKC game cause I want to see if
they're going to close out the warriors.
MMM.
And then, you know, you know, it's funny,
all you need to do is just
watch highlights and you could,
you could still host a show.
You know,
I got to tell you right now, formal on
whoever makes the finals in the east,
let's say Cleveland wins.
I'll tell you a form of
Cleveland Cavaliers or you
got to be concerned with do
to durable Oklahoma Sturdy,
considering they beat the Spurs,
they beat the warriors, it'll to
perennial favorites taught the worst.
Um,
that's amazing.
The shit that they're doing out there.
I wish I was watching it and I didn't,
so I'm going to shut up
about it all right before it,
it's any more excruciating to
all you cons out there. Um, yeah.
So we're sitting there out right in
the fucking show and there's all these
Goddamn fucking
like storm troopers driving up and
down the street. If you see those,
those fucking lunatics,
cops like this,
the riot gear, once you know that
you, you'd think you'd only see them,
you'd think you'd only see them in
like countries where they have like a
dictator,
you know,
with a truck is driving down the street
and they're standing on the outside of
it, holding onto it like just, just way,
way over the top.
Like what the fuck?
I've thought I lived in a democracy.
What the fuck is that? Uh,
they were driving over to like Jimmy
Kimmel because Trump was going to go over
there and say that he was the
greatest panel guests ever. Um,
yeah,
and they're fucking driving
over there like lunatics.
One of the biggest bullshit things ever
is that in this country you're allowed
to protest. It's such bullshit.
You're not, you show up to protest,
you standing there with your sign and
then the cops come down and they beat the
shit out of you.
That's basically what happens.
Or you file for a permit and they tell
you where you can protest and it's down
the street and an up over a fucking hill.
And if we even remotely raise your voice,
you get a Billy club to the face.
And that's pretty much every single
fucking country out there that considers
itself a democracy. Now, the ones
that have a fucking dictator,
you're not even allowed to do it.
They just come out and they shoot you.
So I guess, you know,
compared to getting shot,
it's fucking unbuilt. I just
don't fucking get it. Why,
what is wrong with a bunch of
people chanting with signs?
I'm not talking about the people
start jumping on cop cars,
cause those are the guys that they always
show. But even if you don't do that,
they just come down and they
beat the fuck out of you. Um,
I'd hate to have that job as a cop.
It's gotta be so weird driving down
there going like, wait a minute.
These are fellow Americans.
They're protesting.
This is the sign of a healthy democracy.
And then you got your guy,
what are tear you
to slam a club on their fucking head.
You know, you're going
to ask me. Ha Ha. Um,
but they had like all these
fucking trucks and she,
they were just flying up and down
the fucking street, you know,
and then they'll put it on the news and
there'll eight people that were flipping
the fuck out and that's
all they're going to show.
And then the other thousand that's
showed up and were just short a standing
there and they're all going to get
defined by them. You know, it works well.
I guess I'm doing that to the cops.
Right.
Defining them by all the ones
that beat the fuck out of him.
That's what I like to do.
People,
I'd like to make a point and then I
like to just completely fucking destroy
everything that I said. You know what,
this, this podcast just be, just,
just be called the, I have
no answers. I have arguments,
but I have no answers. Hey, if you guys
visited the all things comedy website,
atc.com, have you been there
lately while you should,
some of the greatest podcasts on
in the free world are on there.
And,
um,
I'd appreciate if you'd swing by and
check it out every once in a while if you
could, if you getting sick of this podcast
is plenty of the podcast to listen to.
Um, let me do a little bit of fucking
reads here really quickly before I fucking
okay.
What do I got here? 1618 fucking minutes
already. I got to get moving here.
All right, here we go. Zip Recruiter. Oh,
by the way, I did, I got to tell you this,
I fucking, I couldn't
sleep last night, right?
So like four 50 in the morning. I'm
just, I'm on, I'm on Twitter and up,
whatever reason,
I'm just fucking looking at shit.
And I put my phone on silence and I
turned all the volume down cause knee is
sleeping next to me.
And then there was a video and I clicked
on it and I thought because everything
was off that I could just fucking
watch it with the sound down.
You know, I was watching
all those things for people.
Somebody falls down and they
put it to a song, you know,
and there was somebody doing
like those fucking, you know,
a burnout spinning around and shit
and fucking slammed into this guy. Uh,
so I wanted to hear what song they
put it to. I didn't want to see that.
I just wanted to screen to be
bigger so I can fucking see it.
And I press play and it came on full blast
and my wife just goes, Jesus Christ, what
the fuck? I flipped out and I was like,
sorry, sorry, sorry.
And then she immediately went back to
sleep and then for another half hour,
you know, I'm still on the phone cause I
can't sleep. And then I hit another one,
like an ass hole,
wasn't thinking,
I just wanted to see what
happened to this person.
And she fucking sat up and she
literally did the Ralph Kramden,
she just goes out
the fucking door
and I wanted to start laughing,
but I knew she was going to get mad at
me and then she just went back to sleep
and I didn't leave.
But I'm waiting for her to wake up
so I can tell her that she did that.
Depending on how tired she is, you
know, cause she might be pissed at me,
might still be pissed at me.
You know what? That's one
of those later in the day,
once at the end of the day when she can
go to sleep, I'll fucking bring it up.
All right, here we go. Oh look everybody,
it's our old friend zip
recruiter.
Are you?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates today.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all
the top job sites and now you can,
um,
with zip
but through to [inaudible] dot com you
can post your jobs to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click you lazy prick.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip.
Rick crude is easy to use. Interface.
I don't know what an interface is.
I've said that's one of those fucking
computer words. Interface. No juggling.
He punched her interface. No juggling
emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by over 800,000
businesses and right now listeners can
try zip
but Croda for free by going to zip
recruiter.com/burr that sip
[inaudible] dot com slash bro.
Hey,
ziprecruiter.com/bar all right hallux.
He looks,
what is it about buying a mattress
that leaves you feeling violated?
Why would you bring up
mattress and violated?
Why would you say that in the
same sentence? Jesus Christ.
What is it about it?
I don't know.
You were loose jeans and bent over
to see how much the mattress costs.
I have no idea. Let's read more copied.
Find out. Is it the pushy salespeople?
Okay, we got mattress violated.
Now this person's being pushy. Uh,
the fake presidents' Day sale
or the fact that you, you know,
you'll regret what you bought
as you do the walk of shame.
Out of the mattress store.
Walk of shame.
Like if you fucking bank somebody
right now, you're wondering why, uh,
those days are over.
It's thanks to Helux sleep where you can
buy a mattress online customized view
for hundreds of dollars instead
of thousand. Go to helix,
sleep.com and answer a few simple
questions and helicase creates you cuss,
create your custom sleep profile
to build you your perfect mattress.
The result,
did you ask?
Evidently their customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
Okay.
Your mattress will arrive at
your door in about a week.
Yeah,
and shipping is 100% free.
You have 100 nights to try it out,
do what you want on it.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free with
rubber gloves and give you 100% refund,
no questions asked. It's like
it never happened. That's,
this copy is so fucking creepy.
You know,
you can do whatever you want on this
mattress. Soil it for a hundred nights.
We'll show up. We're not
asking any questions, we don't
want to know what happens.
And then what do they do?
Do they recycle it in a third
world like an old cell phone? Um,
if you do love your helux mattress,
keep it and your dignity.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helix sleep.
Go to hell. He sleep.com/birth
and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar.
Hey, heloc sleep.com/bird.
That's h. E. L. I. X. All right.
How many more of these fucking
things I got here? All right, um,
the next one. Score big. All right.
You're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups and last minute
convenient charges, even print and
home fees. Are you fucking kidding me?
Over here you end up paying court
side prices for nosebleed seats.
Scorebig is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all
live event tickets go on sold.
And did you know there's a place
to get these seats at huge savings?
It's called ScoreBig.
Well then you bought them.
How did you get him?
The fucking team just gave them to you.
I really don't understand what that means.
Score bid works directly with your
favorite teams. Ah, that's how it works.
And artists to get their unsold seats
at unpublished prices only with score.
So that's when you know you're
fucking nuts selling any tickets.
When score big goes, hey, you want me
to take half the arena off your hands?
You [inaudible] I'm only with score big.
Can you name a ticket price and
be guaranteed to pay below, uh,
below box office up to 60% off.
Here's what you do.
Well,
what do you do to you?
Did you buy up all the tickets
Ashley Simpson didn't sell?
I mean, is this going to be shit?
People want to see one go to score big.
Don't think Bruce Springsteen,
STU ScoreBig once go to one.
Go to score big.com or
download the new score.
Big App for your iPhone and
find the event in seats.
You want to make an offer with score,
Biggs name a ticket price feature. Three,
get an instant answer and save
up to 60% on your tickets.
I got a question. If you fucking buying
up 40% of the tickets, go on salt.
There's no way that happens at Bruce
Springsteen, Beyonce, all those huge acts.
So do you not sell those? Who
Do you sell it for? The uh,
insync review onion reunion.
Yeah, in sync reunions.
Sands fucking Justin Timberlake.
It's all the original people except the
one that hit big. I'm never any fees.
And shipping is always free. You can count
on unbeatable prices and great seats.
And when you're in great seats, you can
actually enjoy the game or the show.
All the more.
Next time you see any game or show,
go to score big first
and see how you can save,
how much you can save for the
easiest way to save on tickets.
Download the new score. Big App
for your iPhone. Like I said,
fucking 10 minutes ago,
enter Promo Code [inaudible] at.
Check the checkout and you'll save $20
off your first ticket price. No iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off online too@scorebig.com
at scorebig.com Promo Code Burr.
Um, hey, why not? Why not right?
Can't all be, what's that other one?
Everybody always goes to stub hub,
right?
It's good that there'll be another person
out there. Scalping tickets, right?
All right. Club Debbie
clubbed club. Me and my daddy,
which led me more than Jean
delivers wine straight to your door.
We send you wine that is personalized
to your own palate tastes.
Uh,
through our pallet quiz,
our recommendations become even more
personalized with every bottle you rate.
We work with top wine makers and growers
from around the world directly make are
to make our,
all of our own wine are $13 bottles
would normally retail for 20 bucks plus a
more than $20, I think is what
they are trying to say there. A,
you choose the type and quantity of
the bottles with no membership fee or
cancellation fee. 100%
satisfaction guarantee. Creative.
We partner with local artists to develop
wine labels that are unique works of
art right now. It club, Debbie,
I tell you I can speak Spanish,
is offering listening listeners $20 off
your first order when you go to club.
Debbie, I wouldn't build a
wall.com/burr and it gets even better.
I know you all hate paying for shipping.
So club Debbie a, he used to go to Yale,
will actually pay for your shipping
on orders of four bottles of more.
So take something off your to do list.
Just go to club.
Debbie had never went to class.com/berg
to get $20 off your first order.
Now that's club Debbie and weapons of
mass destruction. Dotcom. Slash. Burn.
All right, that's it. And
we're out. We're out. Um,
anyways,
what the fuck can I finish on?
I really don't have anything
to finish on other than, um,
I'm excited that we're doing the table.
Read for a number five next
week we write all week.
We don't have a table read and then
three weeks in a row we do episode six,
seven, eight week off just
writing, no table read.
And then nine 10 and then I'm fucking
done in the writer's room and maybe my
fucking ass over here can fucking stop
sending an electric jolts down my fucking
leg
laying down to the room.
Now I feel like fucking like some
Howard Hughes without the money.
This fucking wolf man nails.
You know,
I saw somebody the other day when I was
in the airport and they were playing
classical guitar, you know what
I mean? And it sounded beautiful.
But the only thing that sucks
about playing classical guitars,
you got to grow your nails
like a fucking wolf man.
You know one on one of your hands and
it's all good when you sit and down
playing guitar. But the second you put
your guitar down, you know, you just,
it looks fucking gross.
And I had on my mind
and I guess that's no reason
to stop because a instruments,
you always have to pay the price for like
trumpet trumpets, one of them, you know?
Okay,
start playing the trumpet. You get
that fucking Callus on your, on your,
on your lip. You know, it's one
of my favorite instruments ever.
I love the fucking trumpet,
but I would never play it,
play it because I wasn't
willing to pay the price.
And plus I knew I would only be okay
at it. Who wants to be okay with it.
Fucking trumpet, callous.
Um, not this guy.
I'll tell you that right now.
All right, now here we go.
I'm going to give you my
predictions for all the games,
sixes and sevens out there.
And a,
you can take all of these predictions
to the bank and they won't give you shit
for him cause I haven't watched
any of these series. Um,
the goal of the Golden
State Warriors will,
okay.
When the next Guy Willie, I dunno,
I didn't see the game. All I know is
everybody said the exact same thing.
I'll tell you,
this team is a lot longer and a lot
more towel to the near used to seeing.
Everybody did a version of that.
I guess they're long and
they're talented and uh,
the warriors haven't seen anything like
this even though they played Oklahoma
during the regular season, but I
don't think they were looking at them.
All right.
The uh,
Tampa Bay lightning will
win game seven tonight.
All right, so I feel like I'm o for two
are ready. And what else did we got?
The calves. Oh, the calves are one and
the next one, that fucking series is over.
You don't fucking wag your finger and
fucking Lebron James face or any of his
teammates are. Yeah. To your fucking mind,
you know all these fucking
actors running around bulking up,
putting on their fucking underoos,
playing these superheroes, right.
And all these fucking nerds
going down to fucking checkout.
Who could fucking be when the Hawk or
captain America. And what about Thor?
Well he's calling, he's stupid. He
just says a hat and a hammer, you know,
if you cut his hair is
fucking hammer breaks all this
fucking bullshit, you know?
And then you get these fucking comic
con [inaudible] who actually dress like
superheroes for real and walk
around and try and stop crime.
You know what I mean? Cause they just
so want the superheroes to be real.
Well just go to a cavs game.
You stupid cunt and watch Lebron James.
Okay. Lebron James could grab Batman
and Robin in one fucking hand.
Throw him through a plate glass window
and he'd still get the end one if someone
was hanging off his other fucking arm.
Okay.
Just go buy a ticket and sit down like
a fucking gentleman stopped standing in
line with fucking 50 people dress like
Chewbacca and an an aqua man down in San
Diego. Whatever the fuck you go. Cause he
can sit down and talk to the cast of a,
I don't fucking and one of those God damn
shows. What does, what does, what does,
uh,
what does a car,
I guess mine's a comic con show hot
now that I think about it. Jesus.
I hope they don't play that audio. If
we ever do that show, well maybe they,
what are they going to do?
Throw some of their rough action
figures still in the box at me.
You know why it's worth more if it's
still in the box. Ah, I can't say why.
I can't say ah,
you know why it was fucking Weirdos.
Cause you know it hasn't been anywhere
disgusting. Um, happy red nose day.
What is this here? A people send me
this. Twitter is for kids. You red nose.
Fucko so he just told me what the
red nose thing is for. He goes, it's,
it's for kids. Oh. Is that what it's
for? It's for kids. All that explains it.
I Dunno why I'm such a Douche,
but I fucking cannot stand.
I can't fucking stand when a bunch of
celebrities get behind a fucking cause and
there's a fucking ribbon or
a God damn nose and they,
I don't know why. I just, it drives,
I know it's a good cause behind the cause,
but I fucking hate it.
And then everybody's going to find
their own unique way to have the nose on
their face. How they're going
to fucking hold it. It's just,
it just drives me up the fucking wall.
That and famous people
telling me who to vote for.
Yeah.
Oh, you know what? I didn't know who
to vote for. And then you told me.
I mean, I guess I bitch about it, but
I'm not telling you who to vote for.
I don't fucking know, like,
make a fucking 20 minute video.
Here's why you should
vote for fucking Freddy.
Fuckface you know,
we're running out of water.
Ah, shut up. Um,
you know what's funny
about what I just said?
I could literally just stare in
the mirror and say that to myself.
And a lot of ways, right. I
never tell you who to vote for.
I just make fun of the people you
do vote forth. That's what I do.
You want some comb over orange haired
cont why don't you just vote for me
instead of Donald Trump?
The fuck is wrong with you.
I have the greatest podcast ever.
Okay.
Nobody tells a shit joke like me.
This club owner told me after it,
40 years of running a club,
he's never seen shit jokes
like my shit jokes. Um,
speaking of which,
I'm actually doing a of both.
Where the fuck you want to vote for?
I don't give a fuck.
It's not going to change anything.
We're a bunch of animals and we're doomed
to destroy each other. So, you know,
get yourself a dog and a hobby,
you know, find somebody you like,
treat them nice. Said a, that'd be great.
They'll stay with you and when
the whole thing goes down,
you'll have someone to hug.
Yeah.
Jason. Um, anyways, I did that.
Made me lose my complete train of
thought. Oh, tonight, tonight, tonight,
tonight. Hello. Um,
what was Phil Collins Thinking in the 80s?
Jesus Christ.
He's such a great musician of
the worst fucking songs. After,
after raw [inaudible],
um,
then all of a sudden he was doing,
you can't hurry love after.
You can't hurry love.
Then you did that song
easy lover was decent and then it
just went off the fucking rails.
It's a studio.
Yeah.
And that one where he was yelling at you,
you know,
telling us to think twice because it's
another day for you. A mean paradise.
You know, when you see a homeless person,
it's like, hey, fuck head. You know,
the way I'm living compared
to the way you're living.
You don't need to look at a homeless
guy. Just look at me. She felt lucky.
When you look at me, you don't have to go
all the way down to that level. Do you?
You're fucking castle.
Um,
tonight I'm going to be down
at the comedy still, uh, uh,
doing a benefit for kids.
That's another one,
but I won't be wearing a red nose.
Uh,
but I will be jumping around
like a fucking clown. This
is for, uh, you know what?
I don't know what it's for. It's for
sick kids in hospitals. I have no idea.
All I know is whoever put it
together. Uh, I don't know.
I trust them. Steve Simone. I trust
the guy. So I figured, you know,
I figure it's on the up and
up. Who knows? I don't fucking,
I don't pretend to know things. Um, hey,
is anybody out there who listens to this?
Are you one of those fucking riot police
guys that rides on the outside of the
truck? And when you do it as much
as your adrenaline is going up,
do you ever just think of
how fucking ridiculous it is?
Okay.
You know, like what are we doing here?
We got to get over to Jimmy Kimmel.
Donald Trump is there, um,
what's going to happen?
Uh, all right. And I think, I, I think I
pissed off enough people with this one.
All right, go. Um, I have a great weekend
you cunts and I will talk to you on that
Monday. And like I said, you can take
all of those predictions to the bank,
but I don't think
[inaudible]
hey, what's going on? It's bill burr.
Yeah. Isn't that exciting? It's the,
it's the Monday morning podcast.
How are you?
Thanks for coming to my page and thank
you for listening and thank to it's
Memorial Day. So here
we go. Something Nice.
Thank you to all the men and women who
are serving this country right now.
Sweating our asses off over there in Iraq.
Uh,
I don't know what you're supposed to say
today. Do you say Happy Memorial Day?
I don't think you do. It
doesn't seem, uh, fitting.
I Dunno what I'm trying to see if there's
a memorial day parade out here in La
and it's the, if so, where would
it be? You know what I mean?
And you, well, Memorial
Day parade is a very, uh,
serious thing.
So I can't picture the parade going
down sunset honoring the fallen men and
women who've served this country is the
parade goes by the fucking saddle ranch,
you know, is two whores and watching
some shithead write a fake horse.
You know what I mean? I just don't
know where they will have it out here.
I'm really not up on the parades out
here in la since I moved out here.
I know they had the gay pride parade
and all that's an Halloween. Um,
that one's always hilarious and confusing.
I've never understood the
gay pride parade. You know,
they spend fucking 51 weeks out
of the year trying to be like,
look, we're normal. We're
just born this way. Okay.
For the love of God. Stop tying as
defense posts in Wyoming. All right,
we're not against God. We just wired
this way. You know? And then they,
they had the gay pride parade and you'd
think they'd come down the street,
you know, try and look a little
bit respectable. What happens?
Everybody's coming down the street with
a Dick and the hand, they got fucking,
I just don't get it. You know,
it's just a Goddamn free for all
the fucking spectacle. I
definitely recommend seeing
if you ever want to just, uh,
if you ever wanted to see
what 300 would look like, if
that's what it looks like.
It looks like that movie 300 with
dildos cause everybody's shredded.
I don't know what gate.
Why is it a gay guy put out like a fucking
exercise video? You know what I mean?
It's always these,
these uh,
he's half of fat guys who
actually heterosexual and
that we standing on a beach,
nobody is more shredded that then those,
those gay dudes,
I don't know what it is.
There are,
there are weights in those
deldot's is that what it is? Dhea,
Dhea fucking bloom to the wall and
you do pull ups for something. Oh,
speaking of that shit, I know a few
weeks ago I was talking about, you know,
wanting to get in shape
and uh, I actually, I, I,
you know some about that [inaudible] x
system and a couple of people said it was
bullshit ever. The people said that they'd
liked it. All I know is like, you know,
200 bucks in like 58 DVDs.
I was like a time life series, you
know, on how to get abs or something.
And it was just a, it was
too overwhelming. And I
go on the road too much.
So I found the solution. I, uh,
went online and I bought some,
uh,
I bought rings, you know, those
rings with a gymnast. Shoes.
I'm going to put up a chin up bar today
and I swear to God by the end of the
year I'm going to learn how to
do a fucking iron cross. And, uh,
I just watched that gymnastic
shit and I'd missed,
nobody is more shredded than those dudes.
And there's something I like about
being able to lift your own body weight.
You know what I mean? That, you know, if
you can like climb up a fucking building,
I think that's way better than
being able to bench press a car.
Maybe it depends on the situation
that you're in. You know,
some fat fucks sitting on your chest
going, what are you going to do? Well,
what are you gonna do? But
we do, we're gonna do like,
I guess then if you could bench 400
pounds, that would be like a good thing.
But, uh, I dunno. House fire,
you being chased by somebody. If you go
up the fucking building like Spiderman.
I think that, I think that that's
uh, I have to think that, that,
that's always better. That'd
be a cool thing. Jesus Christ.
They can't get it out bill. I'm
like, I think, I think I did it.
They did that they thought
you said, I thought you said
you wanted one spider. Um,
yeah. So we'll see if I can get you
the website. Here is what this is.
This is what this podcast is becoming.
It's becoming me informing you on the
fucking whacked out shit that I do.
All right. This is the training
rings is where I went to and uh,
www.training rings.com and check it out,
man. I want to be able to do one
of those muscle ups. You know what?
I'm gonna start wearing really tight tee
shirts on a on stage and then I'll be
ready for the gay pride parade.
I brought it full circle.
All right,
before I get into the podcast,
those of you who are on our
new to my podcast, I basically,
I do one of these every week
and, uh, people send me advice.
Sometimes people ask me advice, people
send me questions. I try to ask for them,
answer them. I mean, the
best of my ability. Um,
I dunno, and you know, I don't read,
I just sorta start talking.
So don't really listen to me.
Just I hope I make you laugh or some
shit and I hype upcoming shit that I have
like this week. Um, May 24th,
I have a real busy week
this week, May 24th, um,
the next installment of the uninformed
show with bill and Joe to Rosa,
my radio show,
our radio show,
me and Joe that we do on Xm two o two
was going to be this Saturday night,
May 24th,
uh,
on Xm two o two from
9:00 PM to 12 midnight.
Uh, I'm going to be a Caroline's
comedy club this week,
but it's going to be weird.
I'm going to be there Thursday,
not on Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
Why aren't you going to be
there on, on Friday bill? Um,
because I have to fly back to la because
I'm doing standup on an award show.
Oh my God.
Are you going to be doing
standup at the Oscars now?
I'm going to be doing stand up
at the Spike TV awards show.
I don't know. I never heard of it either.
But, uh, I'm actually Kinda, I dunno,
like psyched. I never got
to do an award show, so, uh,
I'll let you guys know when and when,
uh,
when that's going to be and a usual
that that part of the podcast sucks.
Whenever I hype what I have coming up,
I don't know.
The whole thing starts to grind to a halt.
I Dunno.
And then I never have half the fucking
information. It's ridiculous. So, uh,
all right, before I get into my, my
rent for the week, uh, I actually,
because it is memorial day and I actually
got a really cool email from somebody
who's over there. I don't know if
they're in the army or the marines.
I'm assuming it's one of those
two branches because they're uh,
the appear to be on the ground over there.
It says,
I hope to get back to the states
and come to see you sometime.
A quick story and it was on a mission
the other day and I picked up the radio
and called to my lead truck and said,
is that Pesto in your egg?
The other tactical
commander said it's fair.
I guess it was a little bit of humor for
us. Good stuff. Talk to you later bill.
How fucking cool is that? Huh?
Somebody is talking over them. Falucia
sweeping out the houses or whatever
the hell you do. You know to what?
A couple of my jokes. That was one of
the coolest emails. I have a god and a,
actually you have the name of the
guy who sent me that. So when you,
when you get back safe,
I'm going to hook you up at a show.
All the rest of you
constant listening to this.
Don't start sending me emails pretending
that you're over there just so I can
give you a couple of free tickets next
time I placed slap ease and fucking Omaha,
Nebraska. I right. That's bad
Karma. That's bad fucking Karma.
All right.
Here's my fucking rant for the week or
eight people and I'm going to try to
remain calm throughout this without
losing my shit cause I think it's a very
important thing that a lot
of people are dealing with.
And I'd much rather try
to get the information out
and they may in a nice calm
way.
That way my message will be heard and
I won't and I won't seem like a psycho.
All right.
Forget about the fact that I talked to
myself for half an hour if you become
these fucking things.
Okay.
So last week I was flying to
New York to do the HBO show,
a down and dirty with Jim Norton.
I was very excited to do it.
Anytime he gets to do HBO is a
comedian is a big thing, a big,
big thing. You know, I
was psyched to see Jim.
Jim's the first guy from my graduating
class of Comedians to get a high profile
standup Gig like that. So it
was really cool. You know,
I was anticipating seeing him in the show,
Yada Yada,
Yada. All that stuff. Okay.
I get a first class round trip ticket
from fucking lax. Nope, don't swear.
Don't swear bill. Keep it nice.
I get a first round FirstClass
roundtrip ticket. Okay.
Counting to 10 here from lax to new work.
Okay.
I don't know if you guys
are flown first class.
I do it every once in a while
when I get get a fucking TV show.
I don't do it on a regular basis because
I did that for one month and I got an
$8,000 credit card bill and I said,
you know what?
I don't think coaches that that.
So now I got a free round trip,
first class ticket.
Did I make that point yet? I think
I did. So before I get on the plane,
I haven't eaten,
but I'm thinking that doesn't matter.
I have a first class round,
fifth ticket.
I am going to be wined and dined
from lax all the way to Newark,
New Jersey.
I'm going to have fucking whine and dine.
That's what I'm going to have.
Probably get a foot massage, you know,
little hot towel. Maybe a quick
little, how you doing, you know,
first class.
And we sit there and look down on the
people as they're getting into the back of
the plane. I can like, I'm running
some big successful business,
you know, so I get on the plane,
I'm starving. Oh boy. Oh boy.
I'm going to get something to eat.
Get on. They hand me the menu.
Okay. And one is I got two choices. I
can either get an omelet with potatoes,
some fruit,
I think a muffin and some
orange juice or cereal.
And I'm like, wow, that's
sort of a limited menu.
Who the fuck would get cereal?
I'm going with the Omelet.
Who the fuck wouldn't get
a Vegan?
All right, you got me. But most,
you know, generally speaking,
everybody's going to get the x.
So I go and I read the final
line of the menu and in it says,
please accept our apologies if
your selection is not available.
And I was like,
what the fuck is about to happen here?
What do you mean please
accept our apologies if your
selection is not available.
This is first fucking class. All
right. That shit happens back in coach.
When you sit in row 38 F,
you know,
then they run out of eggs.
They run out of the eggs in the back
where they got people's fucking stacked up
like cordwood. You know, is
that even a word? A quarter.
Quarter Wood?
Isn't it an amount of wood?
I don't fucking know. That's a
question for you guys. What does it,
is that a quarter would I cleared land
one day and I heard that expression and I
just used it and I know
what the fuck it is.
They got people jam packed in
the back of the Goddamn airplane.
That's where you run on x. You don't run
out of fucking eggs and first class. See,
I'm flipping out. Take it down bill.
Make sure your message is heard. Okay.
So I'm sitting there, I started the front
of first class, there's like five rows,
I'm in row four. I'm doing the math and
they're going through and you know what?
Nobody's picking the Siri of course,
the nok.
Why would you pick cereal when
you can get an Omelet? All right.
Needless to say, they get to my route and
they say, what would you like Mr. Byrd?
And I said, I would like the
Omelet, sir. And they say, Ooh,
I'm sorry. Um, we're
out the eggs. And I go,
what do you mean you're out of eggs?
And yeah,
everybody ordered eggs in the
gay were added eggs. And I go,
what do you have left knowing full well
what they had left. And he goes, uh,
we have cereal and a Bagel.
And I looked at the guy and I said,
dude,
I paid for a first class ticket, which I
didn't. Of course I didn't got for free,
but I don't give a fuck or I
don't want to make a point here.
I got to go for big air. I said,
I paid for first class ticket,
I'm not eating cereal. And the
guy was like, I know, I know. Um,
I know you're right. We don't think it's
right, but this is just how they do it.
And I'm like, what do you mean
this is how you do it? I go,
there's like 12 people here at first
class. How do you run out of eggs?
This is first class. I'm not eating
cereal. And the guy goes well on,
on odd flights.
We start at the front of first class
and unevens we started the back row of
first class and it's like,
dude, it's fucking first class.
It shouldn't be a problem. I want
fucking eggs. And he's like, wait,
I didn't say fuck. And I go, I
want eggs. And he's like, well,
all we have is cereal. I'm sorry
sir. And I just said, you know what?
I don't want anything.
Right. Just started pounding.
I'm sitting there fuming stomach is
growling. I got a six hour flight,
I'm starving to death and the widest
Goddamn airplane seat I've ever sat in my
life. So like two minutes goes by and I
swear to God the fucking flight attendant
comes back and he goes, um,
I just talked to the pilot,
the captain of the airplane and he said
he already ate so you can have his eggs.
And I was like, why? He goes to the pilot
said you can have is eggs. I'm like,
I don't want his fucking eggs.
I don't want this fucking eggs.
I want my ex. This is first class. It
should be enough fucking eggs for me.
Alright. And the God, the peace
of pilot, he should get eggs,
fucking pancakes and waffles. Whatever
the fuck he wants. I don't want that.
I don't want my pilot upfront
fucking stop, you know,
passing out all light headed and shit
cause he didn't get any fucking eggs.
It was ridiculous man.
I mean how much fucking money do you
have to mix? This is American Airlines,
by the way. This is American Airlines.
This is how fucking tight they are.
And they're trying to blame it on these
fucking fuel prices. Oh by the way,
I ended up taking the eggs cause
that was so god damn hungry.
And then I felt bad.
I'm sitting there eating and feeling
guilty like I meet the pilot's eggs and
then the other side I'm feeling like a
sell out cause I'm thinking like maybe
they're thinking they're going to give
me these eggs and I'm not going to
fucking fire off a damn letter
on their website, which I did.
It's fucking unreal.
American Airlines are the biggest fucking
cunt of an airplane in an airline.
Do you remember what I remixed their
song a few weeks ago. Remember that
for those of you who didn't,
that was my new thing.
Cause I'm sick of these God damn
corporations and they're fucking,
they're happy jingles as this
screwing you over every single day.
So I remix this song. They didn't
win a little something like that
kid, Eh, fuck it. Yes.
I did that as a joke
two weeks ago and I swear to God,
I've never been more right in my life.
Or the next day I get off
the Goddamn plane bitch.
Then I find out they're going to
charge $15 for your first carry on.
Now you first started the first bag that
you've check and they keep blaming it
on fuel prices.
How the price fuel keeps going up.
And I'm telling you right now as a
passenger, if you believe that shit,
I don't know what to tell you. They
make money off of misery. Okay?
Nine 11 they made money.
Okay?
I'm sure is their expenses go
up 20% whatever. But you know,
they don't just raise a 20 they raise a
25 and that's the same thing with this
fucking fueled.
This is my question.
All right, who's going to start it? Okay.
I'm not starting it, but I swear to
God, if anybody out there starts at,
I'm going to follow.
Okay.
There has to be some sort of fucking push
back because I don't know what's going
on with these fucking, these got
the incorporations they used to be,
the customer's always right and somehow
in my lifetime it's going to, you know,
fuck you and your mother customer.
That's the vibe.
You know when I went to fly back my round
trip, first class ticket, I show up,
my fucking flight is canceled.
And rather than flying first
class nonstop from Newark to lax,
I was now flying coach to Dallas and
then FirstClass from Dallas to lax and,
and there was no voucher. They're like,
yeah, we're not offering anything.
It's like six months ago I would've got
a blow job if you fucked me this bed.
And she's just like, Nah, Nah.
Then they're not offering anything.
You got to call the one 800 number
and then I call the one 800 number.
They're like, no, you have to talk
to the person that's dead. I'm like,
can't I just talked to the person at
the desk, the hung up cause I said,
so then I had to call back and in the
end of it all they gave me was 150 bucks,
which buy like one third of a
coach ticket. But once again,
I won't get any fucking eggs.
So all I'm asking is who's going to start
it? Who's going to start the fucking,
you know, what we need? We
need like a fucking, uh,
what's Charles Bronson's name and
those death wish movies, Paul Kurzy.
We need a fucking the
airline version of that.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
who the fuck wants to pay $15 for
their first bag that they check?
Everybody knows that's bullshit.
Nobody wants to do it,
but we're all going to do it because we're
all just by ourselves twisting in the
wind, okay? But if we all showed
up the first day, June 15th,
or that promotion,
whenever the fuck it is and you show
up at the airport with angry faces and
tortures,
like we're going to go try
and get Frankenstein guarantee
and none of us has to
pay 15 bucks. Okay? I'm not
trying to incite a riot here.
I'm just saying somebody start
passing out the two by fours.
I'm down with it,
all right?
I'm not going to lead it
because I procrastinate and
everybody knows, you know,
they always chop off the
heads of the body falls. Okay?
If I learned anything from the
1960s black, white male seem,
if you fuck with the deal,
you have a comfortable ride
in your future. All right?
But some good things do happen. So fuck,
I'm so pissed right now.
If fucking believe that the pilots eggs,
actually the pilot,
can you fucking believe that
30 years ago. But God damn
stewardesses, they didn't. It was,
first of all, they were all
hot. That's the one thing. Okay.
It was a goddamn glamorous job.
All right?
You had a one in 10 chance of hooking
up with one of the hottest stewardesses.
That's why people used to wear suits.
You wanted to look through.
It was like a nightclub. Everyone
was oozing. People were smoking.
You were having a Goddamn party in the
fucking sky. Here's the one for you.
You know what?
First class used to be,
this is the greatest story I ever
heard as far as the first class.
This is what it used to be as
compared to my fucking out of eggs.
First Class experience. Pan Am
Airlines. I'm dating myself here.
All right.
Pan Am when used to fly to uh,
I think it was John F. Kennedy airport.
I read about this shit on the Internet,
right? So it's gotta be
true. Um, first of all,
the metlife building that's right above
grand central station used to be the Pan
Am building. So when you use the
fly first class to JFK airport,
you got off first class and you,
you didn't go to a fucking town car and
sit and God damn traffic on the lie or
wherever the fuck you go
through the midtown tunnel
and take an hour and a half,
which ruins the first class experience.
You got off the fucking
plane at JFK airport.
They put you on a helicopter,
swear to God.
They put you on a helicopter and they flew
you to the top of the Pan Am building.
You got off drinks.
We're waiting probably more broad with
those scarves tied around their necks
like fucking Dick Cavett
you get another blow job.
Then you took the fucking
elevator down to the first floor,
jumped in a cab,
you went to your hotel pre herpes.
Pre-Aids here's some penicillin.
Have a good fucking time. All right.
That was first class back then. Then, uh,
something happened where the, the wind,
something happened with a wind,
tipped over a helicopter and the blades
went flying down to the street and shot
somebody in half. Okay. But
that's beside the point.
I really did happen by the way.
I forget who had shopped and half,
but he was a son of somebody.
Somebody's obscurely famous, you know,
like the guy who invented
the bookmark or something.
All Jesus Christ. Some fucking
winded after that story. Um,
which brings me to my, uh,
president of advice that
somebody gave me this week. Um,
know, taking naps can really help me out
when I get too negative and agitated.
But this can be hard for
you since you fly so much.
Running and lifting weights
also helps me out too. Well,
thank you for that
advice. Uh, I don't know.
I think the running and lifting weights
would help me out as you can tell with
my rage issues. But, uh, taking naps,
I can't do it. Like, uh, I dunno.
My brain wakes me up.
I don't know how to shut it off.
So if anybody out there knows how
I can shut this fucking thing off.
All right, I'm really worked up here.
All right, here's a, here's some advice.
Somebody,
this is how,
this is a question I get like every week
people will always give me this from
they 50 people say I'm funny.
How do I become a comedian? Um,
I must get asked this like 10
times a week. This is what you do.
Fight five minutes of Shit
that you think is funny.
Sign up for an open mic when
they call your name. Go up there.
Hang on for dear life.
Spit out as much of it as you can remember
tape you said go home, listen to it.
Keep the jokes that work.
Got To get rid of the ones that didn't
and then write some more jokes to take
place.
Take the place of the ones that didn't
work and then you sign up for another
open mic. You repeat the process
and you just keep doing that.
And then eventually you build,
enact. And next thing you know,
you're a comedian flying first class to
a dream TV gig without any fucking eggs.
I don't know you get x, but we're
going to give you the guilt trip.
You can have the pilots egg. He'll just
sit up there and be hungry. What the fuck?
Okay,
it's podcasts I'm sensing is
getting a little long here.
Let me get onto the questions and I'll
get out of here and you guys can get on
with your memorial days.
Okay. Question number one.
You've always seen dimension
sports in your rack.
That was wondering if you were involved
in any fantasy sports leagues. No,
I am not fantasy sports leagues
have for Geeks. I fucking,
I can't stand them. They have ruined
sports. Talk in a bar. People aren't,
aren't like affiliated with fucking
teams anymore. You Bring, oh my God.
You see liking salon.
Really?
Really? What else do you have on
your fantasy team? Huh? A girlfriend.
Somebody who satisfies you sexually.
What else do you have a dream job?
We not fucking walled in by a cubicle.
No,
I don't play fantasy sports leaks.
Uh, actually, you know what?
I don't really know much about them.
I find that sports takes, they take,
it takes up too much of my time anyways,
so I don't watch pregame.
I'm not in fantasy sports leagues.
I don't watch post games.
I don't listen to any of those fucking
ranting raving lunatics that ESPN has
now. Anybody on ESPN for some
reason listens to these things.
Why is every show become two
people screaming at each other?
And why do you guys hype things up to
such a ridiculous fucking level that it
never, you know what I mean? Like
patriots was six and out. They're like,
it just the greatest team ever.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I
guess they are. I mean,
let's completely ignore the fact
that the cults were 13 and eight.
Oh two years earlier. Let's,
let's declare them the Glitz.
Ask if they're the greatest team ever
when there's still fucking 20 games left
in the season. You dumb cunts.
All right. Um, number two, uh,
Bill,
which end of your comedy crowds spectrum
do you prefer to put up with the Douche
bag frat guys who drank so much?
They decided to try and heckle you after
your show while you're signing cds?
Oh yeah. I know who this is. That
happened me in Chicago. Okay. Um,
or the older men who came to the show
with their wives that are afraid to laugh
at your jokes because they want
to get laid that night. Um,
okay.
I definitely prefer the,
the,
the older guys who don't laugh cause
they want to get laid by their wife that
night. Um, because if I pick up
on it, it usually ends up being a,
a much funny situation cause I can see,
I can make the woman's somehow feel guilty
for doing what she's doing. I guess.
I Dunno, riff on it. That's more fun.
But as far and the heckling
you after the show,
cause he didn't have the balls
to do it during the show.
It's just sad and it always makes me feel
like that person actually wanted to be
a comedian.
They just never had the balls to do it.
And I'm watching the death of a dream.
Um Wow.
That was dark.
Okay.
Question number three is a
he slash she a bad comedian.
If they try to talk to the audience.
I have noticed in the last
few years the worst comics,
so the ones that base
their comedy comedy on, hi,
where are you from so they
can goof on the audience. Uh,
wait a minute.
Fucking seem ws so they can goof on.
The audience are the worst comic
smelt. That wasn't me. That was him.
He wrote a bad sentence there.
Even the last time I saw you in
southern California, the Improv,
the two people before you kept trying to
find ways to make fun of the people in
the audience as a comic.
Do you think that this is a
sign that they are a bad comic?
I would think it would turn everyone else
off because they are too worried about
being talked to.
Next one time I was watching a taping of
Frazier in La and 90% of the people got
up because the comic in the stands
with us kept ripping on everyone.
Right? First of all,
let's fucking hilarious.
The guy doing the audience warmup was in
between takes of Frazier was just going,
what are you guys,
a bunch of fucking Douche bags
and 90% of the crowd left.
Um, I don't want to be
a country here, but uh,
I dunno about 90% been like,
just like 30%.
I would think if 90% of the studio
audience walked out at some point somebody
with a clipboard and a headset would
have walked over to the comic and when
would have been like, hey dude, why don't
you fucking tone it down a little bit?
Okay.
Kelsey Grammer's getting a little pissed
because 90% of the crowd has left.
Can you stop calling calling them cunts?
You know,
I know what you're saying though.
What do I think as far as
people working with the,
on the audience?
I definitely know what you mean.
There's definitely guys who don't have
enough jokes. So then they go, hey,
where are you from? What do you
do? What would that job sucks. Um,
but then there's other guys I see fuck
with the crowd and they're brilliant at
it.
I would just basically say,
if you don't have any material and
you suck at playing to the crowd,
then yeah, you suck at it, then
you suck as a comic. Absolutely.
But if you're good at it
and that's your thing,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with it. Jesus Christ.
I answered that like Hillary Clinton.
Well,
I think it could be a good
thing and a bad thing now,
whenever it just fucking elect me.
All right.
Has she given up yet? Jesus Christ,
she's like one of the fucking,
she just won't tap out.
She's like one of the Gracies.
They've got like a fucking arm bend, Ben
Dolly back. I still think I'm doing good.
I think I'm going to win.
I'll take some.
That's the one thing I've
learned about this election.
I have learned that I completely
do not give a shit about race.
I really don't. Black, white,
Puerto Rican. I don't give
a fuck. If you make sense,
I will vote for you. Right.
So my hatred of women,
whooo.
It's fucking unreal.
I don't hate women.
It's just that fucking voice.
Good Lord. And you know, they,
they got to bring it down.
The problem is,
is women,
they raise their voice up because
they try to do what the guys do. Guys,
when they raised their voice, it
has a commanding sound to it. Women,
when they raise their voice up,
they sound like a fucking Segal.
So she needs to do is deliver
her speeches and a middle range,
maybe even drop it down to a whisper
a little bit. And I swear to God,
that's where the female voice has power,
medium voice to a whisper.
It can make your dick hard. You
know, you fix hard. I Dunno.
You're not thinking clearly you're going
to fucking vote for, but when you're,
when you're fucking way up there,
people are not going to hear your message.
I talk more shit on this fucking thing.
All right, the last question. Here we go,
then I'm gonna be Outta here. Question
number four. Bill, you spoke about us, uh,
going home with you. You
know, hearing you, what all,
this is last week's podcast.
When I parked my car in the
garage and all that. Yeah,
we heard you walk up the steps, close
the garage door, which made me think,
uh, what's your take on stockers,
celebrity stockers, if you will?
Uh, she like insulting me, their
celebrity starkers if you will,
celebrity in quotes.
It's God knows,
I love the ATS doesn't count as being a
celebrity, which it doesn't. You're right.
Okay. Um, celebrity stalkers if you
will. Have you ever had one? If you did,
would you be flattered or
freak the fuck out? Uh,
okay. Um, uh, no. Yeah,
obviously who the fuck wants
to be stopped? You know
what I mean? I don't really,
I mean, I wouldn't want to be stalked
by the hottest chick on the planet.
That's how frightening stockers are.
Because no matter how good looking the a,
they have that crazed, um, yeah,
I always think of that, that,
that fatal attraction then I'm
not going to be ignored. Michael,
whatever his fucking character's name was
right then you know what he should done.
Whenever,
whenever I see that movie
fatal attraction, she's like,
I'm not going to be ignored. And she
sort of leans her head down a little bit.
I always wanted him to just
hit her with like a fucking,
just a right cross from a
fucked up angle. Like, uh,
like Roy Jones member used to throw
the punches from those weird angles.
Maybe do like that little rooster
hop and just fucking crack.
You know, there, there's your
attention. Oh, look at me.
I'm like dice clay the end of this
fucking thing. Why am I gonna get this?
This is just brutal. Why? Why am I lashing
out of women here in the end of this?
This is, this is dumb. Okay. Uh,
just cause I'm not going to vote for
Hillary Clinton doesn't mean I hate all
women.
I just hate the sound of the
female voice in the high register.
I think that that's what it is.
Anyways,
let me finish answering this question and
then I'll get the fuck outta here. Um,
yeah, that is, but that is my thing. Yet
stockers freaked me the fuck out. Um,
I don't mind people who are really,
you know, come out to a show.
I've had a couple people come onto to
show it may tee shirts and that kind of
thing. And they act a little zany.
That doesn't bug me, but you know,
later on that night I don't,
you know,
rolled over in bed and all of a sudden
they're hovering outside my hotel window.
Yeah, that would obviously
freak me out. Um, yeah,
I don't think anybody finds
that flattering can. Okay.
I'm taking a very serious tone now all
of a sudden and I'm starting to get
scared. Okay. You happy? That's
what your question did to me.
I'm going to go put on my chin up
bar. Okay. That's what I'm doing.
And I'm actually going to buy a piece
of rope down at the hardware store.
Then I'm going to hang from
the fucking thing and a,
I'm going to be able to fucking climb
up that son of a bitch and I will you
think and we'll bill if the fucking,
I mean, what are you gonna get?
Like six feet of rope? No, this is what
you do. You do get that amount of rope,
but you're fuck actually you get more
cause you want to be able to tie it up,
but you sit on the floor.
Okay.
Would you legs straight out l shape and
then you pull yourself up just with the
arms. And I'm telling you
if you can fucking do that.
My goal is by November two fucking glue
10 likes stance and put them on top of
each other. And that's how I'm going to
end my shows. I need a hook people. Okay,
I'm going to climb right up the
fucking thing right out the roof.
Get on a helicopter by one of those old
Pan Am ones and fly the fuck out of the
Gig. And that's how I'm going
to end it every fucking time.
I'm do a big dramatic way, right as I
go to the ceiling of the funny bone.
Alright, and that's it. There
you go. That's the podcast
for the week. Please. Uh,
please keep sending me the questions.
Please keep back in the or giving
me advice or whatever. And uh,
I will talk to you guys next week.
Everybody have a great week.
I'm a Caroline's this week on Thursday,
Saturday and Sunday.
Friday I'm flying back to La Cause I
have to do a stand up on the spike TV
awards show. Um, next weekend,
the following weekend,
there'll be at good night's
comedy club in North Carolina. Uh,
later on that month,
the 19th through the 21st,
I'll be at the punchline and a Atlanta,
Georgia,
Atlanta, and uh, I dunno what the
fuck I'm going to be after that,
I just put up a of Miami,
Florida date.
What else do I got coming up?
I got some dates in September.
I got Austin in October.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com check of
them out my DVD and my comedy specials.
They're all coming out in
September that Jim Norton,
HBO down and dirty with Jimmy Norton.
That's also coming out in September.
And I'll let you guys know next week when
the Spike TV awards thing is coming up.
All right. That's it. Everybody
you have a week. Thankfully.